many of you have been uh titillated for
lack of a better term by the madison
cothorn cocaine key bump orgy story
uh for lack of a better term and it is
quite quite a name for a political story
in washington d.c we have kind of like
the latest update in this story and in a
second i'm going to tell you at the end
of the day what i think the truth of the
situation is you may or may not have
heard that um recently radical trumpist
republican congressman madison cawthorne
made the claim on a podcast that in
washington d.c he has been invited by 50
60 and 70 year old members of congress
to go to cocaine orgies
at the houses of presumably other
members of congress and this
was understandably salacious and uh got
the attention of many media outlets and
subsequently led to a meeting between
the house minority leader kevin mccarthy
and madison carthorne and during that
meeting macaw thorn uh mcauthorn
mccarthy came out saying
uh corn doesn't know what cocaine is
a line has been crossed as house
minority leader kevin mccarthy after
getting madison cowthorne to confess
that the cocaine and orgy allegations he
lobbed against his colleagues were in
fact overblown
cawthorne apparently blew the trust he
had with mccarthy when he suggested
there was a groundswell of cocaine use
and sex parties coming from his
colleagues in congress
amusing accusations that kawthorne
reportedly walked back during a one
one-on-one meeting
kawthorne at one point supposedly denied
walking it back but it seems he did
and i have a pretty clear sense of what
went on here which i'm going to tell you
but first a really quick word from our
sponsor art list if you're someone who
makes videos whether it's a hobby or
you're a filmmaker or you make youtube
videos the one thing you always need
access to is great music when the david
pakman show needs music and sound
effects there's one place we go and
that's art list giving you two months
free
for one low flat yearly fee you get
access to art lists gargantuan library
of music and sound effects with a
royalty-free license to use them all as
many times as you want worldwide for any
type of project and you can use the song
forever even if you're no longer
subscribed to art list years ago way
before art list was our sponsor our team
evaluated all the different music
platforms and we came to the conclusion
that art list was the best choice
because of the selection affordability
and freedom go through my channel
anytime we use background music in a
video it came from art list even the
music in our youtube trailer on the
front page of the channel that's a great
song that i picked out from art list you
can filter by length tempo mood theme
genre instrument vocal versus
instrumental no other music platform
makes it this easy to find exactly what
you need and you can get access to all
of the music and sound effects on art
list for as little as 9.99 a month and
you'll get two months free when you use
my link down below
okay so what do i think is the truth the
truth about madison cawthorne's
cocaine-fueled orgy stories i think it
is completely overblown
i think that it is true that there are
people in washington dc who use cocaine
i think it is probably true that
kawthorne has heard rumors
about sex parties or orgies but i think
he's cobbled it together in the most
salacious seeming way he's a known liar
he lies about everything but here
i mean listen people use cocaine and
there's no reason to think that members
no members of congress use cocaine i
mean it's just at a population level
out of 435 members of congress some
probably use cocaine and there's
probably rumors in dc as to who's who's
using it um people have sex parties and
uh we know that there's a history of all
sorts of different sexual behavior in
washington dc so i'm sure that at
minimum he's heard rumors about that and
he put it together into one story i was
invited to cocaine-fueled sex parties in
washington d.c i i think it's that
simple i don't think that uh it is
all one
planned event the way he's describing it
but that he cobbled together a few
different rumors to be interesting he's
a liar he lies all the time
um also interesting from the article in
talking points memo house republicans
were reportedly so enraged at
cawthorne's allegations that they called
on him to name names to back up his
recent accusations that he's witnessed
members of congress doing cocaine and
suggested his colleagues invited him to
sex party mccarthy said in private
hawthorne described lawmakers supposed
wrongdoings much differently than when
he was on the warrior poet society
podcast
according to politico hawthorne admitted
to mccarthy he had mistaken a staffer in
a parking garage a hundred yards away
who he thought was using cocaine for a
lawmaker
cawthorne also repo reportedly told
mccarthy he doesn't know
what cocaine is
which also i mean
who doesn't know what it is like now
you've gone too too far it's like when
trump said i've never even heard the
term burner phone it's like okay dude
john bolton says you use them all the
time and talked about them all the time
it might have been better to say i've
not used burner phones but of course i
know what they are so bottom line
madison cothorn is a known liar
madison cawthorne often lies to get
attention
but i'm sure that people in dc use
cocaine and there probably are sex
parties i just don't think it's 70 year
old members of congress that were
inviting hawthorne to go do coke at
their sex parties let me know what you
think is the truth of the allegations in
the story